With you all,
your experience in the military and your,
your knowledge of what the real world in these combat environments is.
Like what do you,
how do you feel when you hear people talk about defunding the military or
decreasing the military or that we don't need it or that we shouldn't have the
kind of budget that we have right now,
the people that don't understand the real threats that are out there and that if
you do not have a well trained,
well funded,
experienced military that really understands these things,
you've got real danger at your door.
Yup.
Uh,
I'm glad that they live in a place where they have enough space to develop those
thoughts because they're not under pressure because the military is doing the
job that they should be doing.
There are,
like I said,
so many misconceptions about what the military does.
Uh,
what we do overseas,
how many countries we are in overseas,
how deep we are into some of these countries,
how forecasted and how forward looking the military is looking for emerging
threats as opposed to just responding and all of that creates space so people
can exercise their right to voice their first amendment.
You know,
right.
Of saying those things.
I don't,
does it frustrate you though,
that they don't have a real understanding?
I'm grateful that they live in a place where they don't have that great
understanding because like I said,
they have the space to be confused.
They're not pushed under a thumb.
They're not being told you have to say this or it's going to be your fucking
head in the square.
Right.
It is frustrating for me at times,
but I balance that with that's,
that's what this country is supposed to be about.
You're supposed to be able to voice your descent.
Right.
And I,
and I believe that the system will correct in is it does correct for itself.
There are people that believe that,
but I think the most,
the majority of people,
again,
silent majority versus extreme minority,
I think those people are in the extreme minority,
but they're very vocal.
I think most people are incredibly appreciative of what the military does.
But having said that,
if you've never served in the military and you've never been in a combat
occupation and then you've never applied that occupation for real,
there's going to be a gap and there's going to be a gap in understanding and
that's okay.
So it's frustrating.
Yes,
but I'm,
I'm glad that it exists and I'm glad that they are not in this country,
is not in a position where they are getting drafted and forced into that
position.
I'm glad that it was me that did that and had to bear any weight or burden that
came with that to allow them to have whatever pending they want.
That's a great perspective.
That's a very healthy way of looking at it.
Um,
and I probably think it's probably the only manageable way of looking at it.
I think you'd go crazy otherwise because the other way.
And then you,
what are you going to do?
Go to a rally and hold up another light.
It's like what's right.
I mean I,
because initially I have to fight back the,
the initial anger,
but eventually it give me a little bit of time and the,
you know,
hopefully relatively sane head is going to prevail.
And I had,
you know,
again that night I got hurt.
It changed the way that I thought about things if I had never gotten hurt and
uh,
and the,
and I had never thought about my own mortality and I had never thought about
like I spent a lot of time thinking about whether or not what I did in the
military.
Has it had any impact 0.0001 I don't know if I would have thought about that if
all I had ever done was just doing the occupation that I did.
I needed that lifting of my head to have that perspective.
I did.
I don't think all people do,
but I needed that.
How long do,
oh,
sorry.
I was going to say,
I think that night in,
uh,
in some ways helps me have the perspective I have now with those people.
How,
how long is the average career of someone who's a seal?
Well,
if you want to retire,
you got to do 20 years in a wake up and they should change it to wake up,
wake up the next day.
You got to 20 years,
you have to do 20 years to the day.
So wake up the day after your 20th.
Uh,
but they need to change the term.
Also,
retirement pay in the military should be,
in my opinion,
at least replaced with,
uh,
money that.